good morning everybody feels like I'm in
church we'll get hush tones before the
minister comes in at uh at the time but
uh
hopefully I won't preaching you guys
um welcome to the meeting that's great
to have you all here
um and it's uh delightful
Southern day
I've been growing to anybody that
listened actually for the first time a
long time I ran around Queens Park
before bricky and it's one of the best
things you can do in New Zealand so it
was great to be out
um we have a full meeting this morning
and um actually I think a very good
meeting and I always like to just
acknowledge
Michael Patricia and the team for some
very good papers
there is the basis of a very good
discussion here for the rest of money
around the assumptions
um and again built on the work around uh
the the risk environment
um that is a very effective paper and I
just want to acknowledge that the other
thing I want to acknowledge is
um this committee has spent a lot of
time vixed in our relationship with our
auditor and it's great to Patricia to
see that we are on time and that we will
spend a reasonable amount of time later
in PX looking at the draft annual report
and I'm much encouraged a bytes quality
and B the position that we are actually
in I realize there is still some ways to
go but actually again it's great that we
are in that position so very grateful to
staff for their work for this meeting it
gives us the chance to do our work as we
should be I need to inform you as you'll
be well aware that we are live streaming
and so welcome to anybody that's joining
us by the way of live stream I don't
believe there any committee members but
if I move for the apologies we have an
apology from Ria I suggest we sustain
one from knobby for lateness he is in
the building I understand or at a
meeting but will be with us and I think
that's his laptop so somewhere you're
going to come and retrieve it in which
case we'll say he's prison I'll move
from the chair that we sustain those
apologies thank you Tom all those in
favor please say aye is against us
carried thank you are there any matters
of your personal interests that may or
may not impact you in the course of the
discussion
informed Liz of any person wishing to
speak can we move to the minutes please
of our last meeting which was the 18th
of July they're in your agenda
and I'll move from the chair that we
resolve the true and correct record
thank you Leslie is there any questions
comments accuracy that people would like
to make on that
there are a couple is but I don't need
to get worried about them I think there
is aware that there's a couple of words
that need to be corrected
um can I just ask
um one question which I didn't quite
know whether we had met under strategic
risks
and I'm now looking at page
12 of our agenda number six requests a
further report on the Strategic risk
consistent with the newly defined
sources of risk and taking into
consideration the risk that it's
identified during the Deloitte Workshop
be presented the direct next risk and
Assurance committee meeting
hey I was struggling to remember what
that was but B can I ask have we acted
on that request is that actually is part
of our papers Andrew you're hiding
behind the pillow there mate
I thought
the assumptions is really dealing with
many of those strategies
we might come up with another one we
might follow up with another one but I
thought for this meeting that would
highlight many of the issues that were
sortably highlighted in that paper I
think that might be the case though
thank you for that so yes that's being
followed up on Stephen even the actions
are right so the other points people
like to make another case I put the
motion all those in favor please say aye
all right
right we can move into the internal and
continuous Improvement update welcome
Peter great to see you again buddy
foreign
I'll take the report of red I've got no
additional areas to highlight but one
comment I'd like to make about a piece
of work the quality assurance team
continues with these the processing of
council's uh the documenting of
council's processes using the tool
process manager formerly known as promet
to date we've processed approximately 4
740 of councils processes and procedures
so these are available in the cloud to
staff members and the push behind this
is to capture our corporate knowledge
and document it but it also allows for
easier onboarding induction of new staff
and to capture the knowledge of those
longer serving employees so it's another
area of work that the quality assurance
team's been working on
thanks Peter
appreciate your report again gives us a
good good direction as to where things
are going to have questions repeated
it's great
um just with regard to
um the issues do we have a schedule of
what's being audited and when
you see internal auditor has an annual
plan that has previously been put to the
committee but I can put it to give it um
as an Annex for the next report well no
it's probably just when does that come
annually to this committee yes
and then just sorry a second review
um
with table one continuous Improvement
requests
the information management
um
open ones 25 qualified percentage is
that
something to be concerned about or is it
I'd be Keen to sort of understand that
in a bit more detail
it's it's a work in progress with the
management team it's uh new for them to
have internal auditing on this area and
it's mainly working on their
um maturity framework for information
management and taking off as we go
noting I had to submit this report over
a month ago so there has been process
made since the report was submitted as
well right so with respect to those open
issues that's been reviewed by yourself
yes and is there anything there that's
of concern around the protection of
information or the public or anything
like that
it's all yeah it's uh
completeness with public records act Etc
is all on track right
thank you Ron good question like I do
think um Patricia if you could just note
this next time one we do actually have a
program for the committee which we
should actually keep as a as a
um as a regular in other words each
meeting attachment for a committee to
know what our plan is for the year
number one uh number two Peter I think
it would be good if we just had us in
Nix what is the internal order program
um that would be helpful because as you
say Grant it's useful just to keep in
mind what what is the nature of the
Assurance yeah that we're receiving
during the course so
um thank you for that offer Peter yes
and I'll take you up on that if that's
okay other questions for Peter
just a couple for me man
um uh and and I was deeply encouraged by
the work that's going on around the uh
the kpi data audits
that makes a lot of sense given the
increased emphasis which I think is
correct from the order of the General on
our non-financial information and I take
it this flows through into the quality
of the the information that we're
providing in the annual report
it may be more a question for Patricia
but frs48 is the new or revised standard
for thinking about actually how we show
that data and the systems behind the
assumptions and everything is this
assurance review consistent with the
frs48 requirements
take this one I wondered if you should
um it is
um we have
um from those looking at our processes
and looking at the standard we have
pretty much been on Iris of of PBE IFRS
48 for a couple of years at least we've
only had to make the moment touching
wood some minor changes yeah for
compliance in the annual report that's
still subject to audit and I suspect
they may have different views on a
couple of points
um but yes we have it's to make sure we
have that assurance that those numbers
that are coming through on a quarterly
basis into the quarterly performance
reports
are accurate and that was the reason why
we've started doing those brilliant look
that's that's great to hear and I'm look
I'm looking here Peter of the long game
yeah um but but quite rightly
um uh the Auditors should be as we
should be when we get to the annual
reports spending as much time on the
non-financial information and there's a
clear expectation that we will
um
uh um pay due attention to our systems
and processions of the processes of data
collation and actually our assumptions
and what have you behind it just as we
do with our financial numbers so if over
the long term the work you do here picks
that up that would be really good I'd
encourage you to sit down with Patricia
and she can tell you everything about it
for us FRS 48 you want to know
um look just Again The Continuous
Improvement program and I just wanted to
check something out here you praise
information management for the
proactivity then looking at the um
and a proactive release reviews he said
I take the same assumption that solid
waste the proactive over the findings
that you have made there yes yes they
are chipping away at that one that's
been a change of personnel within
infrastructure which has slowed down the
um
but timely action on some of those
recommendations yes brilliant
um can I just check a couple of things
here on the list of continuous
Improvement requests we have a couple
that seem awfully similar but again the
preps it reflects Grant's question what
is the plan we've got we've got
information management information
management maturity framework and we've
got invocable Transfer Station review
and invercargill transfer station
there's separate line items so is that a
double luck or is are they two separate
sets of audits over the same area uh the
information management are two separate
I will
confirm on the transfer station I
believe that's a double up
right even though even though the number
sections made a difference yeah
yeah
um yeah sorry wrong oh look just after
you cheer
um look the only other one that I had
then was quality assurance
what is that all is it that's just uh
recommendations and internally within
the team for changes to our quality
manual Etc oh okay and how we do
business internally
um
try to uh yeah walk the talk when it
comes to what we get other people to do
good on you yeah well done that's
tremendous to actually
here
um uh and sorry I'll get you but I just
want to check one other thing under
table two
um
uh the infrastructure contract
compliance
can you just remind me what that is that
it strikes me as a relatively important
review it was um we've got a number of
recommendations coming out of it it was
the review from uh the external water
partner on the compliance mainly
focusing on the waste management
contract yep and the compliance uh on
all parties with that contract and it's
a work in progress there's been a change
in infrastructure operations manager
which has slowed down the progress on
those right okay I just I mean like I've
you again in terms of information sort
of value you've always characterized the
outstanding risks and their moderate and
not at least major or significant or
extreme but 16 moderate particularly if
they relate to one contract
suggested we were to focus but I hear
your point that you've hit staff changes
and so it's it's slowed and I'll be
looking for progress in the next one
which would be great yes rangi you've
got a question buddy yeah look
um
you've you've raised two items on the
transfer station and then in table two
with the infrastructure compact contract
compliance now as chair of the
infrastructure and also on the wastenet
committee
um we are totally unaware of this it's
not brought to our committee agendas so
is this appropriate that we only find
out about it here or uh or would it be
appropriate that we
uh briefed in those appropriate
committees
well fishing I'm not having a crack at
uh Solid Waste can I say that I just
really no no no no no but I'm just
saying that's um that's in front of me
um
the answer is yes I would assume your
committee would know all about this
okay
um um and perhaps when we get to my
review of the committee we might want to
re-raise this question because I think
one of the work ons that is needed is
actually the relationship of this
committee with the rest Council
because we are doing valid work here
which is which is we are asking Peter
and indeed our deloittees to to work on
a internal Assurance program I would
have made some assumption that you would
have been aware of this but equally
you're here as chair and you've got a
chance to see that we're doing good work
in this area um but equally you're
probably going to be briefed on I would
as well
yeah it's Michael yes thank you through
yourself chair
um that will be in relation to the fact
we've had those staff changeovers and
the person who was tasked with a lot of
the actions um has is the one that's
changed over I would hope that this will
be taken through to waste it in relation
to giving them the same information that
we'd be able to share with this Council
so
um to my knowledge they've only it's
only been highlighted it had they have
not had the detail at this stage so we
will Rectify that and we'll actually
take our own team out there to discuss
what we've done as an internal audit to
them would that be more appropriate for
way stamping their cargo transfer
station or through the infrastructure
committee
you can have both if you would like
Council
so thanks to racing that rangi as I said
I it it's a you'll find a fertile ground
discussing that with me because I'm very
interested to see how the work of this
committee which is important and needs
to do its work but how does it how does
it provide confidence to the rest of the
governance groups Council that actually
things are okay rather than there being
an assumption thanks for that
um Peter believe it or not that's my
question but Grant I think you're next
yeah thanks dude so just Michael so
what I think you heard you say was that
um it hasn't been reported through
infrastructure because someone's not in
the position
uh throw yourself chair yes the intent
was that the operation infrastructure
operations manager would be taking that
and presenting that through we've had
vacancy in that role for a couple of
months that has now been filled so we'll
be in a position now to as soon as
they've taken on both the
recommendations be able to present those
up so that can be rectified pretty
quickly
so so is that a common practice that
they're reporting an assurance program
is reliant on someone in the role I we
haven't got a process that sits the
irrespective of who's in the role so
because I would have thought that
there's a process that says it comes
through infrastructure and if there's
someone not on the role someone else
does that but it still goes through the
same process it's not dependent on the
person but the role being someone
holding the position it should there
should be a process for where
particularly you know assurance and
compliance goes to
yeah through through yourself chair
um normally there would be in this this
case all um internal audit and external
audit need management comments and
feedback we weren't in a position to be
able to
um
and pose there on on the incoming person
without them having the chance to review
through those actions so we'll give them
time to actually look at those actions
and and put the management comments to
come back
um if they come through
um there are times when some of those um
continuous Improvement actions aren't
actually required once it's gone through
the management comments because there
there may have been something missed so
we actually need to make sure
um that management has time to digest
and actually provide feedback in
relation to those actions
sorry it doesn't give me any confidence
because what what I'm hearing is it's
still related to
if if management Let It Go through or
there's management there that can
comment on it then the committee will
see it it should be that the information
goes to the committee if there would be
a comic put on the report that a manager
hasn't been able to review it or a
substitute manager has
because you know
if that's the way we're doing
compliance and Assurance across the
organization it's got a few holes in it
through yourself chair now we provide
both sets so you get the comments
directly from the audit into an order or
external order and you get the comments
from Management in this case there is no
management at the moment there's no
management comments available because
there's no manager there
no no but we're talking about why it
hasn't gone through Rangers committee
um if I can Stefan here typically we
haven't been taking the this this
particular one that referenced actually
came to this Committee in its last
meeting with the um executive summary if
I remember correctly we typically don't
take them back through a second
committee
um unless the chair would request them
to really come through which is what
councilor pottinger has asked now
because this is the committee that deals
with the the
so
because you get double up
if we were to take the the findings from
an internal audit back through through
two committees
um because their internal audit program
is the um
is the principal part of this committee
well I mean we've got the three cheese
being myself Darren and ringing here of
the respective committees I certainly
know from finance and projects I'd like
to see them through my committee before
it comes to this committee and I think
ring is saying the same thing and I'm
sure Darren would say the same thing as
well it's of that debate I mean this is
driven by our order and risk committee
okay in your insurance program has
proven off should be driven off a sense
of what are the risks again that's
something we'll come back to when you
look at my review of the committee work
program so that we are a proper risk and
Assurance committee having said there I
think there is a there is a there is a
good good reason Peter that we um and
the issue's Not Yours by the way this is
actually to understand
um a your process in terms of uh once
you're doing your work what is the
process to get that report cleared
before it comes here I think equally and
I've tried to signal that twice now when
we get to my review of the committee
you'll recognize that I am saying the
connection between this committee your
committee Grant and the others is a work
on in my view and I think the discussion
we've had shows that there's a work on
and we need to and we need to solve that
reasonably quickly yes Darren so can I
just clarify then what committees are
the performance reports
coming through here is the
four of those performances
no I think I think um we're saying and I
think we need to keep it simple
um we want to have a risk driven
internal Assurance program and
um uh Grant it started the start of the
conversation asked what is the annual
program that we have and we've asked
Peter to help us as the committee by
just annexing the program as a standard
item behind this paper
um and that should be driven by a
combination of the executive in this
committee
agreeing to an internal audit program
annually
so that I would suspect needs to be
tightened up and it doesn't matter
that's number one so number two the
reporting
of Peter's work or indeed deloitte's our
external providers for their work
is with the people that are they are
auditing so that would be the the the
solid waste manager
um and to report to this committee I
think Patricia probably is shown the key
if we've done it formally are there
grounds for us to resolve that this
report go to the subject committees
sorry I don't think I was clear the
performance of those different
departments comes through our committees
whereas the report oh you're making the
same what do you do yes yes thank you
sorry buddy yeah I preached it you
didn't know I said I shouldn't be a
picture today yeah
yeah no no I appreciate you more
okay so I've seen so we would have
unease about this so we need to work on
this one and and I'll uh um well again
let's let's just perhaps work out where
there's a couple of actions that come
out of my review of the committee's work
because I suspect this could well be one
of them Patricia that we should we
should have as a work on
right Leslie thank you it's it's okay
cheer you actually made my point that I
thought this was a discussion we were
going to have on the next section
good right in that case thank you Peter
um it shows you the relevance of
internal audit so can I
um move us to the recommendations which
is that we receive report if I move in a
second or please thank you grant thank
you Leslie is there any discussion on
the motion no no put it all those in
favor please say aye aye those against
it's carried thank you very much thanks
Peter appreciate that man
right if we can move into the the item
uh you might recall this was held over
from the last meeting mainly because uh
I think I was late for the agenda to be
perfectly honest and I didn't want it to
I didn't want it to um
um come as a as a late item
um uh what I would like to do is just
essentially open up a conversation but I
think probably for me to work through my
slides super quick would be helpful
um I've always said that we should
annually review I think we did in the
prior year we had a short survey of
staff and councilors in terms of their
thinking in this situation I have done a
self-assessment if you will of where
we're at and I have thought that useful
to do a couple of things
firstly where we have come from
and essentially on my first slide and
under
um or after purpose I'm reflecting a
change emphasis and indeed the
conversation we've just had is is is
symbolic of where I want this committee
to go in my view which is that we do
normal risk and Assurance work
the work that we were asked to do
and and with reasonable
rationale behind it there was a broader
focus on this committee and you've seen
there under the changed emphasis of
working on working together which is
um at the stage when we had uh Grant and
Lindsay with us
um
there were some big issues that you can
see there around ICL lock and obviously
the the legal claim
and quite frankly we've had too much
time spent with our auditor trying to
get an ordered out of the way that's
still valid work that's all valid work
actually because they all reflect risks
but having since since that the program
this year
is one where we are trying to be a more
traditional risk and Assurance committee
can I say I think personally my sister
what are we where to go but that's uh
that's neither here nor there so look
I've just wanted to reflect under the
program and focus my appreciation and
effect of your attendance it's been
great and regular and we've had
additional people here I think the thing
that I'd want to reflect is again as I
want to do I do reflect the paper the
papers qualities are improving and I
appreciate that and I'm very
appreciative that we're getting the
Financial Risk update the Omnibus one
which has been an important conclusion
that you bought Patricia
um uh however
um I do think if I was to move over to
Direction setting for 23 24. I'm
reflecting here
what I consider
to be
um probably the three key areas that we
should look for development in this
current year
the first one and I call it the
centerpiece is nailing our strategic
risks Andrew is taking us through a a
process and we see the fruits of that
today when we consider the assumptions
in terms of looking at the risks around
our strategy but believe it or not there
is still work for us through to complete
what is that what are our strategic
risks what's our risk appetite
and actually starting to govern as a
committee based on those risk
assessments
because if they're real we should be
driving the use of our Resources by
the second thing is actually just what
we talked about
an effective internal Assurance program
our role is to be aware of the risks and
to also be able to give give governance
your colleagues you and your colleagues
assurance that we've got these things
under control
or whether but actually we're outside of
our risk tolerance in which case we may
have to recommend that there be action
and the third point is perhaps I should
have put better after our discussion
this morning ongoing communication with
the full Council because in my
experience this committee doesn't have a
strong relationship other than through
you folk in terms of the messages that
this committee should could be giving to
the broader Council
so um I noted a couple of other points
right at the end there we do struggle to
leave it with time and you might want to
have a crack at me over that but I'm
fronting up
um and there are some things that I
would like to see uh more regularized
which is time with
firstly Michael
it would be conventional for a risk
committee to have time with the chief
executive on risks
um it would be normal for a committee to
have time with the auditor external
order we do and actually I want to
reflect we should also do the same with
our internal auditor if we understand
the role of the internal they are they
have a quasi-independence inside an
organization including the ability to
talk direct to our risk committee so
those are some of the areas that I would
like to move the committee into hey so
that's the Robertson self-assessment I'm
very open now to discussion and comments
from folk if they would like to make it
is running
um
so looking at our governance statement
and where the risk and Assurance
committee
sits in its definition there how do you
feel about that how do you do you
believe in a government statement
actually sums up the role correctly what
we have there because it's actually more
written about
the role of the risk and Assurance
committee then the other standing
committees yeah yeah it's quite it's
quite complex so is it overdone or is it
right on the money
um I think it was I think it's
reasonable at the stage uh rangi and I'm
also trying to drive my assessment of
these changes through through quite
frankly my experience of what is good
practice
and I would come I trust I would reverse
engineer it I haven't looked actually in
the government state but I come back and
reverse engineer the government
statement if it isn't fitting for us
because it does state that I mean
obviously it's it's a relationship with
Council and also other committees now
like we have joint committees waste Nets
one of them so so would this committee
have a have that relationship with
wastenet and the risks involved or
um I mean this is this you raise a good
point
um in short
um uh I think
we need to
um uh we'll put it this way let me back
the truck up
we have a responsibility for group risk
okay the risk of the invercargill city
group not just the parent
and we've seen we've been well served by
that through Andrew and indeed for
instance the development of the ICL
block and we have been aware of the
risks and the development in the course
of well actually the last couple of
years or so is that as that has
progressed why
because we should have a responsibility
around group risk so to the extent that
actually
um uh uh the joint committees and you
mentioned wastenet is a particular oh
that is a particular strategic risk the
answer would be yes we should and
um just taking it a
another step outwards uh Great South now
we are a shareholder of that in the
sense that we're a shareholder of polka
or whatever so obviously risks involved
with that are they is that something
that that we need to be aware of or do
we or do we just separate ourselves and
let it happen it's a good it's a good
question it depends on the relationship
but I would I would argue that we should
have an increased relationship with
those entities that are our ccos
right okay being quite different so let
me give you an example Auckland
we meet quarterly or we have a quarterly
report from all our ccos on their risk
environment in profile
and every quarter we have one of them in
to talk to us about their risk profile
so the reality of it is yes there is
significant room for us to have as a
committee
of for the benefit and I want to stress
this because it goes back to the
communication issue for the benefit of
whole Council
have a more effective relationship
across the group
the water dealt down to their compliance
or they have their own they have their
own audit mechanism themselves I would
be expecting to understand for any CCO
whether it's ichl
um or whatever what is their own risk
management and and Assurance approach
and
what are their risks
okay now that's enough rather than
rather than this being a vehicle to
um uh uh question their performance that
would be dealt somewhere else no no it's
about compliance yeah
Tom
I think I think actually to some extent
you've just said what I was going to see
which has that well you've raised
um a specific point at the risk insured
Assurance committee I think more broadly
a question for this committee is as to
what extent are
counselors in particular able to
understand from information that they
receive the totality of what's going on
in the organization and I I think that
is a very valid question I mean we to
partly answer that every counselor
receives every agenda
um every counselor receives the minutes
of every meeting
um you can therefore say that if you
know sufficient work is done on those by
that counselor then they can piece
together all of the little all the
little bits and put it together in your
jigsaw yeah
um but there is no opportunity to get a
can of overall view from say the
chairman of each committee feeding back
to council and now there isn't an
opportunity for the chief executive to
give a you know state of the nation to
council which is and and I think both of
those things actually are
lacking in my view
um again coming back to the question how
does an individual counselor collect all
of that information in the form of
pieces of jigsaw puzzle and actually put
it together in a jigsaw puzzle which you
know without the opportunity to ask
those questions so I I think well you've
raised the the matter
with respect to the art committee
specifically
um I think that is a broader question
which is actually still part of the
working art committee to think about you
know how to be minimize the risk a lucky
communication across Council as a whole
by the fact that we don't do those
things we don't have face to faces with
chairs for example um thank you Tom
appreciate that comic
I agree any other comment folk would
like to make is running you look just
following on to what this committee does
it states
in our covenant statement for this
committee that this committee
period periodically meet with ichl and
group now
this committee this term has been going
um one month's shy of a year and we have
not met with ichl
um and I'm just wondering
like a week
you know is that supposed to again
that's in our governance statement
and I'm a great believer that whatever
we have written in our governance
statements is correct
you know otherwise we we take we take it
out
so that particular statement meeting
with ichl and obviously there's
you know a heap of risks with what they
do
what's the state of the nation there do
we Indra lucky you want to invest in the
song so I'll let you out a crack to a
certain extent um
there are two things I'm sorry about my
voice
um two things is a general proposition
in terms of those formal uh
almost quarter little six months we have
everyone inside and catch-ups they've
been held between ichl and Council
because the starting point is that
Council uh or ichl reports the council
correctly I think this was specifically
referring to during the ICA ICL
development and we did have the report
coming up uh from the holding company to
this committee around ICL and I think
that was at least in my mind addressing
this question because there was a clear
line during the development phase we
switched that though with this new
committee structure where that reporting
as it's gone from development to
um operations has gone over to finance
uh to be reported to that committee and
so it's probably just it's a good point
to pick up we should review that so
whether or not we want ichl to continue
to report here in its own right
um and or what we're doing with that Ico
reporting
um but it also States next paragraph
says
this committee needs to be briefed on
ichl's annual report and the results of
its annual external audit uh prior to
the committee improving Council and the
group's annual report so that's another
part
that
yeah
when we actually bring the annual report
through there is a section in that
report that says this is the result of
what's happened from the ichl group so
it's not ichl presenting to us because
that's what it says in the government
statement
well
I see HL often in the room by Andrew or
fire Luke
but not specifically because they've
it's been pulled into the council report
it's not extract too many hence teeth
here I agree no no I agree with the
wrongy the answer is yes we should yeah
and we haven't so um that's my you know
that's that's what I'm wanting to
reflect here I didn't put that down
excuse me directly as if I had three
points to improve on which is that which
is uh Direction setting that I have put
there I wouldn't have included that I
mean it is it is one I'd love to knock
off but the critical thing is we need
strategic risks we needed we need
equality inter internal Assurance
program and we need better internal
communication
and that I would I would happily pick up
these other issues as well but I'd want
us to focus on the top three in my view
we nailed those top three this year uh
we're in a we are in a better position
but I agree with you the governed
statement says that and I would
personally you can see from my
background and I've mentioned already a
council as an example I'd like to see
exactly what their government statements
is
okay I think I have got Grant been
Leslie was it wrong yes crafting list
thank you yeah thanks to you so I you
know it's been talked a lot about risk
maturity in this organization and
I think
we we need to determine you know what
the purpose of this committee is
excuse me and fundamentally I think it's
about whose responsibility is risk and
the answer there is everyone's it's just
that what level around managed
monitoring or monitor management control
and
so I think there's
the first thing this committee needs to
do a resume quickly is to find the hell
that is going to be done at different
levels so that we don't overreach
but equally as members of the committee
we don't sort of in your whole load of
the chair
you know have a CCO come in and we use
that as an opportunity to interrogate
around something that not is not
anything to do with risk relative to
this committee that's right and
you know I think if we can get to that
point then we
you know the level of maturity we've got
in the organization has enhanced
significantly so I think our role is to
say to ourselves how are we helping the
organization
get more mature on its risk at every
level
and that's the first piece we need to
get
get the work done on Define a purpose
and then determine okay what does it
look like managing risky is it life get
it
it um
Splash Palace versus
you know the water treatment station
versus Financial Risk with some of our
ccos
I think I like I'd like to make a coin
if I could Grant agree yeah I mean I
think I I think the the phrase I go by
that is helpful
for us as we are risk Governors yes we
are not Risk Managers and this boy is
the chief residency
our role is to ensure that he
is managing risk
so it's not sorry pointing at you mate
it's not it's not it's not to it's the
old story isn't it we're not we don't
get involved donkey deep in the
management of risk that's not true we
govern
and so the question becomes what are the
information flows around risk that
should come to this committee
that enable us to govern
that's the critical that's the critical
bill that's why my first point here is
developing a strategic risks moving us
into risk governance is the critical
the critical thing along with hello
assurance and communication very
entirely we want to know that risk is
being actively managed through our
management team
uh out of Interest what it's worth for
me that puts us puts a lot of focus for
us on elt
listen
thanks Mr chair
um
and thank you for the paper it's it's
good to have the reflection in the um
Direction setting
look edits
trying to put it at a simple little
level
one of the reasons I
am always interested in being on risk
and Assurance committees at any
organization I'm on the governance Board
of
is because for me the risk and Assurance
committee
is the governor's protection if you like
against those things that should or are
keeping us awake at night
that's why I'm really pleased that
you've got the identifying of the
Strategic risks
so high on your list
because I actually believe that's the
that's the absolute core it's those what
should keep us awake at night how as
Governors do we ensure that we do have a
handle on it so I was very pleased to
see that as the top thing you had
identified and then the the ongoing
governance I agree we can do as we've
already discussed but to improve the
communication and the matchup between
the Committees this committee and others
and so forth but look for me the
absolute concentration on identifying
those strategic risks for us as
Governors is the essence of what this
committee is about
um if we in 23 24
actually achieve that level of
identification of strategic lists to the
point that all of us on this committee
and all of council feel that we have a
handle on those issues
particularly the top ones that
keep us awake at night and how we are
prepared for them so there are no
surprises I think that alone is
um a huge Mark of success for this
committee so just wanted to say thanks
for the paper thanks for the
the clear setting out but for me that's
that's the absolute top
thank you Lucy
going around the committee I'd rather
I'd see knobby uh Darren Ross who
welcome my comment soil right it looks
like you've got some comments
sure just listen to the comments um
I think there's a potential here to
overreach this committee onto too many
things
it's a little bit like order the
discussion we've had recently ordered
just keep topping it up and Topping up
and every time you get a in the area
that you feel uncomfortable it goes to
risk committee and next thing you know
um full Council of doing nothing but
rubber stamping the outcomes all the
reports of things
um I think risk and is the biggest thing
we face as elected members
um publicly and yet
um we've only got half our legal members
here on this committee
as you can see and so one of the things
is by the time this gets to the full
Council and and gets six and gets
received
um as I think Tom said
um some of the council wanted to read it
that was the first thing
um and but even if you do read it the
minutes are not reflective of a lot of
the stuff you just discussed it'll just
be an oversight and that's that's we've
made those decisions with the Committees
that we won't detail verbatim everything
because the minutes get way too long
um so I am a little bit worried about us
being too a risk-averse
um in the framework going forward I mean
I'll race with you what does the
committee actually doing and what should
it be doing I I would like to think that
we have
um an annual identification of what
strategically at risk for us going
forward we've got to identify some of
those things now and yes the cost wise
of these meetings don't become all-day
Affairs
um would be that we'd have to
acknowledge that some of the reporting
currently comes to us come to us legally
and it's all okay that we should just
let that slip so instead of having a two
monthly report maybe we might just get a
six monthly report which makes space for
the stuff is strategic I think we should
also uh touching our what I caught up
with what
um
Grant and rainy were talking about as I
came in uh was you know we should have
an ability also for the cheers to raise
a risk that comes past them that's not
necessarily on this agenda
and I could think of a couple recently
um so the cheers could say actually that
needs to go through and we have space to
be able to accommodate that I think that
would be helpful
um I'm not sure whether we're mature
enough to uh take the ccos and and just
talk about risk without getting into
other stuff so we'll just be very
disciplined on that because otherwise
this committee will be all uncommon soon
and and like Andrew said we made
decisions early on that hold code would
report to Grants committee which is
finance and project and that's where it
should still go but the risk aspect of
it probably still needs to come here but
the flips aren't there there's just
about every paper I see going through
just about every committee's got an
element of risk in it because the staff
quite Riley we've asked them to do that
they put in the financial implications
of the paper they also put the risk in
there and it's rare not to have some
risk so you don't want everything that's
got risk to come past this committee I
mean we'll be here all day and and the
internet so I guess getting that balance
I guess would be helpful
um
and
um I'm
very in favor of the quarterly reporting
of risk from the ccas I think that would
be helpful
um I'm not sure about the chairs and the
chief Executives doing a state of the
nation because that is much wider than
just risk
I think they should be reporting to full
Council and we don't get that at the
moment but we should have that full
Council level otherwise all Council full
Council will do is just reinforcements
from all meetings including this one
my opinions with thanks look I
appreciate it I don't think you and I
are too far apart and in fact I hope I
hope actually you've mentioned the word
overreach
I'm trying to make certain that we
indeed do what our role is which is as
the title says risk and assurance
I guess what I'm suggesting is risk is
everywhere look at it it's a little bit
like health and safety it's everywhere I
agree but I think I think what I want to
reflect again I mean I I'm sensing the
potentially even a short workshop on on
risk risk management for us just the
discussion the career would be not a bad
thing
um uh I want to reflect
that I agree and I presume all your
Council papers do have a session for a
section around rescue it doesn't mean to
say it's only gets home back to
here what I want to know
is actually what is the maturity of
thinking of Michael and his team as they
fill out that risk resection it's a
systems issue that we need to know
because that is evidence for you
ah start thinking effectively about risk
none of those few of those need to come
anywhere near here unless they are
strategic
the other thing which I think is really
important you raise not be if I could
while we're talking about riskers indeed
your point that actually not only should
we be dealing with
um strategic risk and and I want to
reflect a point that you've made Leslie
that that's the key thing we need to
know and actually this is the Good Year
to do it because you're adopting your
ltp so if you're strategic risks aren't
related to what you want to achieve
those opportunities in the ltp we're
wasting our time
so um it's actually a really good year
to get ourselves nailed on that one
um uh uh but I think actually again
within the agenda we should allow for
the dealing of emerging risk
you know we're gonna we're gonna have
health and safety strategic risks we're
going to have disaster preparedness and
I'm about to say they're reasonably
stable they're not if you live in the
North Island and if we're about to go
into El Nino it's going to be different
for us but the bottom the bottom line is
we should also be aware of emergent risk
because often they can take over and be
indeed the Strategic risk I guess that's
what that's what I was coming to chair
was just the fact that it seems to me at
the moment this one piece of Jigsaw
missing yeah at the moment we get
um standard reports from the risk people
yep um this committee identifies the
risk going forward and Michael can do
that
um we get the risk identified on air
reports but it doesn't seem that the
chairs actually say actually what's
sitting in front of me today is a bit
more serious I think that needs a an
oversight of the risk and Assurance
committee or it doesn't yeah
um and we don't seem to give any
referrals that way it should be I think
it doesn't mean we don't think about it
no no I wasn't saying that no not at all
right I wonder if I could get us to walk
oh sorry if we got a funnel I've rung it
you had your hand up do you want to make
a final comment as well I'd like to
bring this towards a conclusion
um where I'll try and sum up and we'll
we'll work out what perhaps I'll go but
what I wanted to raise was is it is it a
role of this committee
to
go over for the purposes of preventing
the same mistake happening again and I
want to bring and I hope no one
interrupts me here is the litigation
against her Tim now is it the role of
this committee to learn the process we
went through
purely the process because obviously we
started off with the QC got advice and
then we I went in a merry dance and
insurances and stuff and then we ended
up doing that is that something the
committee would learn from or or someone
would learn from obviously to to at
least be in a position a better position
say next time it may occur I'm just
wondering if if that's the role of this
committee or is that elt just doing it
separately adjusting I mean obviously
you must learn from things like this and
could we have done it a different way or
whatever so I'm just wondering is that
the role of this committee or
or
um well God I mean probably oh I'm going
to say everybody in the committee's been
around us actually it's not though I had
fears that we dealt with it in the
previous training the answer is yes
I think we do need to learn from all of
these and indeed some of the stuff that
we have discussed uh in this committee
probably in PX is stuff that we should
we should be with our chief executive
thinking through what is what is
the lessons that we have learned out of
it so you know in a sense if we can talk
about the legal claim that was risk
crystallized we had an event
so any good committee it's a bit like
what we're doing here today just to
review an hour and performance would
look to see what other learnings out
there
we were disciplined that would be the
right way did you want to respond to
that yeah I think ring erase an
interesting point because
um Tim's not the only one if we had one
in the future that we were facing at
risk around
Personnel or something similar
would we repeat the behavior again I
think there's a place for the chair of
this committee to
take significant events and and do a
short Workshop where the parties sit
down to analyze how they handle it what
outcomes they got to what would they do
differently next time
otherwise we just repeat the behavior
thank you thank you for your point
running uh Grant and then Ross yeah
thanks Jude so just thinking about where
to Next in terms of the
um
the risk with to your comment around you
know how well was Michael and his team
overseeing those for us would it be
reasonable for us to seek a report from
Michael at the next Committee just as an
initial sort of Catalan and I'm thinking
about you know the report will received
from Peter which you know as a as a good
look at Assurance risk the report
received from Ura and his team around
the health and safety we're on a journey
so that but what are the other areas and
then what's here sort of
level of confidence capability around
understanding risk in each of those
areas would be worthwhile I think from
my perspective out of interested in your
view and other committee members just as
a sort of initial sort of okay well this
is where we're at and then we can start
to get some structures and discipline
around how we lift
um those things I'd I'd be very happy to
take that one on advice I I don't know
whether quite at the moment but we
should
um mystery have a paper but I think
myself with Michael in with Andrew
should take this on on board and we
should work through what is the next
steps out of here because yeah because I
mean I think if I could sum it up and I
know Ross you still want to have you say
perhaps perhaps we can accept from a
self-defense bit of past Mark but could
do better
um I don't know what teachers would
write these days on report they still
write reports I don't know um but
perhaps I do
um that that actually your
um uh I can't put into NCAA credits I
don't know
um uh uh that actually there are clearly
some actions that that I'm sensing you
folk on out but I mean I'm wanting
change
um and we should try and just catch and
crystallize what is the road map to
Improvement to be honest that's what we
really need and I wonder whether the
three of us should just put our heads
together if the committee was prepared
to accept that rather than just think
there's an immediate report which I
don't have you know I'm agreeing with
you but I think it should be there
Ross and then Leslie
I'll take our board the counselors
comments
um and without going back I guess
the overreach or the expanded role has
become of circumstances over past years
but I think the focus in onus going
forward a bit of bonus on Bruce and I to
get the agenda sitting right which we
have a pre-meeting with Michael and
Patricia so I think it's uh Arrow to
make sure the agenda's right and then
encourage the right Focus for the papers
coming through for this committee and I
think we get that right we're on the
right check without yes
um yeah going into the rest
you've got the final comment down so
Leslie then Darren okay we're right
okay look I was just going to uh
actually I agree with what Ross has just
said um but I was just going to make the
comment from the other comments Grant
and others it would seem that your
suggestion of a regular slot for the
chief executive
is probably something we're heading
towards rather necessarily than a
one-off report that regular overview
slot I think would be useful for this
committee
and I want to reflect um it's obviously
I've seduced it at least Lee and and you
made comment on it knobby
again that needs to be risk focused
you know it's not about it's not about
yeah you know
um what should be going to council or
indeed the other committees this is
actually about risk I mean
um my personal preference is I keep it
verbal with Chief Executives I do I did
have a chief executive order would
regularly give me a 16-page report was
which was brilliant but I want to make
it relatively I want to want us to be
able to learn to walk pretty quickly
but simply what's keeping you awake or
not Michael
you know somebody I think you use that
phrase Leslie which should be focused
around risk
and I won't share what other count what
other techniques they're going to say
but Michael I'm sure there may be one or
two things and indeed it might even be
actually I'm sleeping well there isn't
anything we it's always an opening thing
what are your chances Michael yeah
it tells me every time I see him that
everything's going fine
you've got final say mates the pitch
with which he uses the word foreign
I think I like the the tenure of the
report one of the problems that we face
in my opinion is the word risk and risk
really applies to everything that that
Council does as a yeah for some degree
and and there seems to be attendance if
you think well if the word risk is being
used then maybe it needs to come to a
risk and Assurance committee which it
doesn't
we're around process rather than the
operational side the operational side is
what comes to the Committees and with
the likes of the holding company for
example and those other ccos it's
I think our interest in my view is how
does that uh reflect on that annual
report how does that feed into our
long-term plan and and that's where it
sits rather than
having to be across everything no thank
you dare
question it's the last one yeah okay so
just I said no have we got to commit
this is the final round guys you've got
about three minutes just following up
the election or the proposed action so
Michael yourself and Andrew will sit
down and go through and present
something at the next few minutes I'd
like I'd like to suggest and can I
include Ross in that sorry yeah
independent I think it's important that
you lean on us in the way that you see
Ross I think we should if Liz we could
have a um a second point that uh
um uh the cheer and I'm going to consult
comes back with a
um uh a program to develop yeah the work
of the committee for yeah
yeah well it's lit well let's leave it
open
um I mean I want to say to the current
year that that's that should be the
worst quite frankly we should be looking
for three years out yeah that's right um
and it just will I mean most 80 of that
is to reflect will reflect the regular
rhythm of what a normal risk committee
does yeah uh which we broadly have but
they'll come back
and that'll come to the next committee
but that'll come to the next committee
yes yep no reason why not uh I can't
promise that for the 25th the 25th to
solely about the annual report yeah okay
but the the next quarterly meeting will
do that I'll just use the other 10
seconds that grants with me yeah um I
know I know you always have the last say
yeah
um
it was a joke that was a joke Nobby
when I think back to the last term we
this committee agree significantly
and and in part that was because of the
dysfunction we had in council at the
council level full Council level that we
then move to a model where the
Committees were a whole of council and
therefore the risk and Assurance became
a safeguard that a one-off council
wasn't doing the wrong thing it was
another layout of safety now that we've
gone back to the more traditional model
I think from my perspective we've got
another level of security there that
what goes to committees subsequently go
through a full Council for a decision
um and and that that avoided there was a
risk in the whole Council approach to
make an on-the-spot decision and then go
away and think actually that wasn't the
right the right decision
so
thank you and and I agree Navi the value
of what I have put here is the focus is
because I think we've normalized
ourselves I mean working on working
together has gone and the sense of
hopefully the legacy of its thinking and
approach is still there but
the absolute implementation was the big
Focus we can get past that we can focus
on risk Assurance there goes the uh the
recommendations
um uh and look good at smart report I
don't feel like I should move can I ask
somebody to move this thank you grant
thank you Darren is there any discussion
on it we probably need to call it a
program sorry Liz I'm glad my probably
my spelling is probably well I don't
know somebody's probably found it was
typo and my stuff
um uh can I put the motion please all
those in favor please say aye those
against us carried thank you thank you
for that uh great discussion it was very
helpful and I'm deeply appreciative I'm
glad you take it seriously it's good
um can we move on to an equally
important paper which is again within
the remit of the committee which is to
look at estimates judgments
um in key inputs to the ltp not the
policy decisions that you make around it
um that's for for Council so the ltp and
Rhiannon welcome to the table I suspect
we need to hear the highlights or key
points you want to make for us please
um so yeah this report deals really with
two matters the process to deliver the
long-term plan itself and then the key
underlying assumptions that will
um are intended to underpin it
um so I'll just note the stage that
we're at in the process
um
means that these are draft assumptions
and it's important to take them as such
there's still a lot of iteration to go
through over the next few months ahead
of consultation my paper speaks to the
higher than normal still continuing
level of uncertainty in the environment
it speaks specifically to some things we
actually expect to land over the next
few months to increase certainty which
may result in changes to the underlying
assumptions
um so I'll just speak briefly to where
we're at in the process the ltp is on
schedule
um all of the Strategic level workshops
have taken place and the direction which
has been given by Council has been taken
through into the workflow
um pre-engagement has been completed
um we've had clear direction from the
council right at the beginning from the
beginning in terms of the vision and the
community outcomes which has been very
helpful to officers in terms of
developing plans
um we're now into the budgeting phase
will flag do expect though to be quite a
bit of iteration through this phase
given
um the impact of things like inflation
the reform environment expected changes
within the program to maintain
compliance
um
the biggest risks to delivery Remain the
uncertainty in the policy environment
obviously should there be any
substantial change to Direction
following the election to the affordable
water reform Resource Management reform
local government reform or any of the
other environmental program policy
changes that will impact this Council
then we are ready to Pivot on those but
they will be expected to be a delay
um the other factor is really
um
the ability of officers to deliver what
we expect to be an intensive budget
round program obviously that relies on
on individuals that have been tied up
with annual report elements as well
um there may be a situation that may
have result that should sickness or
anything like that impact we'll need to
look at backup options
um
it'll be a metaphor Council to consider
how they balance any of the risks in
terms of
um
being unable to result in decision
making I don't see that as a massive
risk of cancer in My Views work well
together over the previous nine months
but there's no doubt a um it is a
challenging economic environment
in terms of the assumptions themselves I
wonder could I just interrupt really
Iran I wonder whether it would be useful
just to get questions about process
because I certainly would likely viewer
to focus on the assumptions but I wonder
if at this stage because you've raised
some really
important well they're hurdles I'm about
to say they're impediments they could be
impediments to to the process I wonder
if I get any question about process
you're obviously donkey it as in
contrast to Ross and I but are there
risk related questions about process
just two Reflections on the process
um the feedback I get there seems to be
good governance participation at the
workshops this round last time Ram
probably remember get to the end of the
process and you're struggling for a
quorum but it's been good turnout which
is a good reflection
um and I also get very good feedback
about live streaming the workshops and
that's not just from the cargo I get
other councils looking at our live
stream at some of our workshops which I
thought was interesting I think quite a
quite a few approaches about you know
how do you make that work and how do you
still have the full and Frank discussion
so you know that's been really positive
brilliant
Tom
uh
I think the the question I'd have a bit
process is the fact that well you know
those workshops have been great I mean I
never experienced some last time but I
think they've been very very good
um in comparison I've seen on boards for
example I mean I think it's extremely
good process the the assumptions that I
see though in this paper don't really
drop out of those workshops they're
drawn from other places so that if you
take for example you know I'm just using
this as an example I'm not going to dive
into the assumptions but if you take for
example questions like you know how much
will the population of invercargill grow
will it grow at all will it grow by you
know the 5000 that's seen in here
um that decision to make that assumption
does not commit to the workshop
the workshop kind of talks around it but
the Assumption comes from somewhere else
so I I it it does seem to me that one
thing that's liking it and I'm going to
look at all of the assumptions I'd say
the same thing about all of them
um the the actual assumption doesn't
come from the the workshop
um you know there's no question what
should we assume about population growth
you know that's another debated
in the workshops and maybe it should be
because you know the these these
assumptions are key to you know how we
take the long-term plan forward
um but they they are drawn from other
places
rather than the workshops themselves I
would say if you look at each of them I
think I'd betray all of them
can I speak to that chair so um
certainly that's why they're being
brought to this committee because
they're fundamental to how we manage the
risk and build the budget and the
delivery
um
they are important to underpin the model
for example estimating the population
and the number of households within a
certain range of accuracy is important
to estimate the rating base and to
estimate the rating Revenue
um
so
I hope that unders explains to a certain
point but that is why we've brought it
to this committee for discussion
appreciate it I appreciate it they're
not workshops and you've made a good
point about that Tom but I noticed this
is the first of at least three times the
assumptions get visible immediately
there's three committees but but this is
just the start in terms of this broad
range of assumptions
I mean I I just wonder whether an
appropriate Workshop actually would be
to discuss the assumptions yeah
um because we don't do that
[Music]
well the population of a chemical
increase a decrease how about climate
change effect I mean all those sorts of
things are either bearable
um and and we don't do that workshops at
the moment
okay so let's take that on advice about
that that's that's that's a workshop
question a process question I want to
thank you for that time I keep it there
because we're going to come back to the
assumptions there's a committee so
Andrew you've got a point
the only thing I would say and this this
sort of goes back to the earlier
discussion really it is the higher level
the ones the assumptions that have more
significant impacts that will be debated
here with the lower level ones with less
impact we're probably not I mean you
might have a workshop and deal with them
but those still come up here as to how
they're managed how Council adopts the
management of the the higher level
residual risk rating
um so it's a bit of chicken and egg I
suppose but but it's the point this is
the first time through they put the
numbers are put in there from external
sources so Council can debate them
ultimately they've got to be council's
assumptions and how you get to adopting
those assumptions is really a matter for
yourselves whether it's through a
workshop or through a discussion here or
or whatever way works
Brad
thanks Chief yeah it's a little bit to
Tom's Point um
so just to respond to that comment you
know I think it it's important that the
workshops did see do see the assumptions
up front now that may change or evolve
and what get disagreed or whatever but I
think it informs the discussion in the
workshops
um more fully in my
my view and the other point I was going
to make I mean the workshops have been
very well it's good to hear the feedback
from Rihanna and others that they have
been very well participated at and
engaging
it's probably just post those
workshops what's the output before it
comes through the committee so we get a
sort of a summary on certainly from my
perspective you know just a summary of
the discussions and then there were a
big opportunity to pick up around okay
you know was there a discussion about
the assumptions or have we moved or
changed because the purpose of the
Workshop is to sort of get everyone sort
of roughly to the start line isn't it
and so I think
you know seeing something output before
we see it through the committee would be
helpful for the attendees just as a
summary
um to allow further reflection before it
comes through it recommending
right and I think you've got a response
well I wonder if the rest of my
comments on the actual assumptions will
be helpful in some of this as well in
terms of the process and how we've
arrived at them and at this point
um I'd like to go there I just seen our
head opened up and I want to stress back
to process and I've taken these on
advice around the process rather than
necessary about the assumptions
themselves at least I think you had a
point and I was really just going to
make the slightly contrary point to what
um
Tom had said that my view of the
assumptions was that as they currently
stand they were a mixture of things that
had been well
discussed in workshops
and some external figures Etc but just
because Tom used a few examples things
like the age and population the housing
issue the
Community resilience around the Ty Point
issue Etc
um
they're they have all been discussed the
CBD
City Block development Etc they've all
sort of been exhaustively past part of
the background of various workshops
so I had seen them the assumptions is
pretty much a reflection of a lot of the
workshop discussion that had already
taken place as well as
um quite a bit more
um external figures Etc brought in and I
was interested to hear a bit more from
Rihanna about about the assumptions but
I just wanted to make that point I don't
see them as something that is entirely
external
Darren and The Nobby
um
from previous ltps the Assumption around
population growth has always been
something that's that's been determined
by Council but my question for Rhiannon
is
is it the process of the the census this
year and when the figures become
available
which is probably not till next year
early in the next year
um one of those things that holds up
what enables us to make a more accurate
assumption because we're running on a
previous census figures which were kind
of dubious anyway because of the effect
that was conducted during the pandemic
so is is the arrival of those figures
one of those things that'll help
crystallize how we make that decision
absolutely
um counselor so that's what my report
also speaks to the
quite a large range of inputs that go
into these assumptions and I'll speak in
a moment about some of them Landing
later than normal due to the uncertain
environment that we're in
I think you're in I'm sorry I know I did
stop hearing your float I'll just keep
going the final final couple of
questions we got knobby I think and then
just I mean just to reinforce what Grant
and Tom have said I mean I don't think
it's productive for this committee to
sit here and take this the wrong way to
go through all the assumptions and drill
down and say how did you come to that
conclusion I think a workshop
just on the assumptions just before this
meeting paper comes up would be helpful
so that before I was like I've already
asked Brianna probably how did we get to
19 Maori population given that the last
steps I've seen say the South Island's
9.8 and invercar was previously 17 and
we're still working on the old stats so
how we jump to 19 and how do we protect
25 because it changes your thinking and
going forward and the same for the three
water spaces but later on we know that
regardless of where it comes we might
need an alternative water supply so the
other things that we could do in an hour
just to run through and understand the
sort of logic behind what the staff are
telling us because this is the basis for
the long-term plan it's quite critical
but
we sit here now and go through all these
we're going to be here an hour later
asking a whole lot of questions
um the guy I'd like to accept some
validity in the assumptions and that
they're here
providing this committee a wake-up call
and great account so and take the
household one for example it it says and
10 11 years time there will be just shy
of 4 000 more households which means 4
000 homes houses so isn't that a wake-up
call to us that we sit here and talk
about more houses
but talked is not going to get us there
in 11 years and it shows that action is
needed and obviously you've got the
pillow one that's going to provide maybe
but if we've got an assumption that says
just shy of 4 000 homes
in 10 years and 11 years then we it's a
wake-up call to us I mean it may not be
right on the money
but at least it shows a number that is
significant and that that
too much talk and not enough action when
it comes to freeing up land to build
houses
is going to catch up with us and we're
going to be in the crap in this
committee should just acknowledge it and
pass on that recommendation to council
you know and and this is what I see this
as it doesn't have to be bang on but
these assumptions are a wake-up call
thank you for that comment ringing can I
just ask my final question it's a
process question
um and I'm looking at the the uh the
um page 26 of our agenda where you've
got the table it looks like current
current base planning 28 November seems
to be a hang of a big meeting
many parts of the ltp process are coming
together correct correct so that's uh
that's a critical stage and you've
indicated in your paper after there are
a couple of things that could derail it
and obviously policy decisions
particularly in the National environment
that who could or could not flow from
the elections are potentially a
potential to derail that correct
factors to manage that we're expecting
it to to obviously impact if there is
change
um Affordable Auto
the way that we've prepared the activity
and asset plans means that we're in a
position to change track moving from two
years of budget through and bringing
other work through it will we have or
always signaled the risk of that is that
it increases the chance that we may need
to come back and rework because
um designing the program for transition
is likely to be different to what a
program looks like if that transition is
not happening is happening later or is
happening under different circumstances
with different elements of three Waters
but we are in a position to continue
we do have the December council meeting
which is about three weeks later that's
our backup for
um stuff arriving
um there is of course audit
implications for three Waters
particularly but we anticipate there
will be guidance from government on how
to deal with that because it will be a
national issue
so
um
it
at this point we're still
happy enough well I'm confident you've
given me a awareness you've you've got a
couple of plan A's and plan B's there
which is um which is important so it's
impressive to see that kind of starts do
we because we run the relationship with
do we have an ltp engagement letter and
fee
less Chef not cheap as I understand it
um Auditor's still working through with
the office of the auditor general
about how ltps will actually be audited
Chris may be on online later we might
ask them where that's at
um so that is actually one of the issues
isn't it is that from our deadline
perspective we have to get an external
player in this case Chris and his team
in here to do work which is a risk might
I say that becomes if we're facing say
an affordables water risk affects our
timeline I think there'll be 62 other
territorials whatever the number is that
we'll face exactly the same issue but it
isn't it is something I'd be very keen
for the benefit available and put to
this process that we we should follow up
on where Chris is at so that Brianna and
team can know that they've got an audit
that's tied in okay so that's that's
critical and then it's probably too far
at this stage to to reflect too much on
the bottom part of that table it makes
sense but there's a few other widgets to
get in place before we get there Brandon
I'm sorry I did um break you in your
flow and I should really get to invite
you to speak to your assumptions
so um the report speaks to the number of
different elements that have gone in to
the assumptions and cancel the low
raised the issue of the census
um there has been some lower level of
accuracy in the forecast coming out of
the census which we actually adjusted at
the time of the last ltp in terms of our
one percent growth forecast for
population so we had already factored
that in and councilors may recall that
we
um undertook another piece of work with
infametrics around the last year's
annual plan to deal with the greater
level of uncertainty
um around particularly some of the
economic but also population assumptions
at that point
um the assumptions development for this
ltp has been slowed somewhat by the work
that infametrics was doing for the whole
region for Beyond 2025
Landing quite late
so um we have absorbed that information
and cross-checked it against the
forecasts we already have and that's how
the population assumptions including the
diversity assumptions are flowing
through or speak to the matter that the
mayor raised specifically around those
assumptions just noting that
invercargill and Bluff do have higher
um rates of Maori population and that
population is younger so as the rest of
the population ages
um that's why what is underpinning that
change in population assumptions and it
has been modeled for us by infometrics
based on NZ stats data
um there are a number of other pieces
flowing into the assumptions that we're
essentially wanting to leave flexibility
as late as possible some of those are
around their economics
um we're all aware that we're still in a
more volatile economic environment and
economists are kind of preaching caution
in terms of looking forward and certain
levels of certainty so they remain
higher than expected
um in terms of key factors like
inflation and interest rates so
counselors should expect some
level of change going forward on that
um we are fairly confident where we're
at in terms of the information that we
present at the moment
um
all of the earlier workshops presented
information as best as we would know it
at that point in time but as my report
speaks to there are some quite lumpy
things that will affect the region that
are actually still not landed some of
them may land before the ltp and that
will improve the quality of our
assumptions others are likely won't and
so we have tried to put that into the
assumptions table in terms of the level
of certainty that we have around them
and the mitigation and management
approach
um
so
I think
that I've tried to write my report as
simply as possible and trying to give
the picture of where some of the things
actually since the previous set of
assumptions are actually bitter than
what was expected in terms of
at the time of writing the last
assumptions counselors may remember we
were expecting quite a deep recession
that recession has not actually
eventuated although we do have the cost
of living situation that we're dealing
with we've seen some really positive
things in terms of international
migration numbers and tourism numbers
bouncing back much faster than I think
anybody including the economists who are
forecasting expected to see
um also City Block the work that we've
um that the teams had done in terms of
looking at the social and economic
impacts which were the reason that
Council invested in it we're seeing
those impacts
um
however there are some significant
headwinds and we don't yet know how all
of those will land and some of them
create a significant amount of
uncertainty for Council for example in
the area of economic diversification and
the extent to which that will flow
through in terms of network requirements
which are separate to network
requirements that might be driven by
population growth so invercargill's
network is was built for a larger
population than the point we have at the
moment in time so we've been able to
grow over the last few years without
having to significantly grow the network
however some new industries that may or
may not eventuate
depending on where they are actually
located are likely to have impact on the
network
um so that is something that um
that Council needs to plan for that
uncertainty housing's been discussed
um the research that's been undertaken
by Great South shows that rather than a
direct shortage of housing what we
probably have at this point is a
shortage of the right types of housing
for future growth and there's still work
that needs to be done in terms of
understanding just how much of a
constraint that is and what is the most
useful thing to do about that
um so I'll just end noting the um
uncertainty around the reform agenda and
policy changes that will impact both
Council directly in terms of our
operations but also potentially
indirectly in terms of impact on
agriculture as one of our key sectors
and impact of wider water quality
changes and requirements that will flow
through and impact whoever is operating
the three water system
thanks Siri and I just wonder if I could
just ask um before I open it up just a
couple of clarifying questions so we've
got the risk tables which again was
built around particularly a piece of
work Andrew you asked the last meeting I
seem to recall around likelihood and
moderate so we are in the business here
forecasting not our not of reporting
about past transactions
um and and I mean you you're you know
you're indicating that even from
previous stuff some of the assumptions
have filmed up with or you've got new
information or better information
um can you just tell us what is the
importance though of the likelihood and
consequence assessments
for us now as we look at these
assumptions
so for example some things are fairly
certain demography
um aging population for example we know
how old people are now and so therefore
we've got a really good idea of what the
age profile of the population will look
like even if you get a higher level than
I expected of migration at a macro level
it doesn't have a massive impact so we
can be fairly certain around that other
things are a lot less certain obviously
Ty is one of those elements we haven't
actually put in the likelihood yet
because we're hoping we will know more
by the time we actually get to the point
we don't yet know whether that's gonna
happen or not
um fty closes or remains open has been
modeled by The Economist as part of
Beyond 2025 it has different flow on
impacts
um in terms of the impact on Council if
it remains open it's a minor impact for
us we've put it as a moderate impact if
it was to close that's not purely from
the flow on impact of a population
change in relation to employment or the
flow on impact to Industries but also
the flow on impact to the community in
terms of resilience for example so
um
where there is a greater level of
uncertainty for certain elements
then we may have to invest more in
planning for alternative options
thank you and I think that's probably
where I'm trying to unders get to which
is is you know when I see particularly
the we've got a moderate or a major
consequence that actually says
um actually if something happened and
assuming that it's you know I mean it's
either like I appreciate the likelihood
thing as well I guess I'm trying to get
to what is the level of scenario paying
we're having to do and I think that that
question I also have is I can and have
read this line by line but what happens
if six of them move
and actually we we you know we we have
inflation
um uh well you know I can I can make it
make a a possible guess that that four
or five of these might all move in
adverse ways how are we allowing for
that and now thinking and our planning
so I think that's a really good question
and we haven't fully scenario modeled
worst case scenarios I think our
response in that situation would be
likely to be rework if af8 goes off and
there's a major earthquake then
um we know how we will fund a response
to that but what it looks like the whole
plan would have to change in response
um some other mixers we have our
benchmarks and the debt ceiling Etc
which is how we kind of look to measure
a risk scenario of a number of those
changing all at once
and most of them are not like af8 they
would have a moderate impact when it's
looked across the whole Council budget
um but certainly there's something that
Council does need to consider and that's
why my paper speaks to the higher than
expected level of uncertainty which is
what economists are signaling
um in that kind of environment sometimes
Council will need to decide do we need
to be more cautious or shall we carry on
with this plan and just accept that in
this circumstance we may all be back
here much sooner than we had hoped
reworking what our plans are for the
future
thank you so I've got Nobby and then
Grant and then Tom
um to your question chair um I don't see
a lot of risk in here and even though
some are moderate and Beyond certainly
the climate change ones are always going
to come up and bite us be it a flood
albeit an earthquake
um I think the big one that really
jumped out for me is the water reform
but it's actually not the reform if we
get a right-wing government and it seems
like that potentially that's where we're
heading
um they will cancel the reform and I
guess what we're left with is the
biggest reason
so
um with climate change over the last two
or three years we've run a bit shorter
water so that alternative water supply
for us is huge
it's got an 80 million dollar tag to it
and the other issue is we're creating
quite rightly talks to is the issue of
Economic Development which involves um
some very large plants hydrogen plant
for example but also aquaculture and
Bluff which will require us to upgrade
our water system heading to Bluff and
that's another 25 million dollars so
that's huge and it's important I think
it's important
um once we get
some understanding where the new
government's going to go whichever one
turn that we revisit that one because
that could suddenly put 100 million
dollars back into our
long-term planning at the Fairly front
end
and that creates risk for other things
that might wrap around them
think snobby and Alex I agree we can't
we can't plan for every scenario and you
shouldn't plan for every scenario it's
probably the most you know what is the
what is the most probable next one from
where we would hope to be
um Grant and then Tom yeah thank you so
um
that's a little bit to your point around
the
you know would you expect to see on this
paper and I think you've it's a very
good paper because it starts to sort of
generate up the thinking which is great
this on the column to the right the so
what and I think that's what I heard you
sort of start to think about and that's
probably something we need to be
thinking about and equally to answer
your question running around
um how do we manage some of this risk if
if I think through
um
you know some of those big investors
coming and needing support from Council
around infrastructure or Network
that to me is something that then would
be taken through to Safe Finance
and we would start to look at okay well
we might sort of ring fence a portion of
capital which might be in our debt cap
or it might be
however we do it so that we can
potentially fund that if it comes to
pass and if that starts to to your big
companies start to come in and start to
do an investment we can then work out
okay well through negotiation are we
actually on the hook for that or uh is
it going to get funded by central
government or will they you know do want
a bit of turmeric developers
contribution but at least from this
perspective what we are doing is we're
we're sort of flagging it in and finance
to say well look let's keep this
on a radar and plan it into our
budgeting in terms of our Capital
program or how we might fund
um is a bookmark and that's how I see
where we would start to use some of
these yeah Flags through to the other
committees as an example I'd be
interested in other people's views on
them
okay
Tom
starting with assumptions are credible
it probably represent the
you know kind of central estimate of
probability on where we might land on
these things
but there is a significant range of
possible outcomes and that's the point I
think that you're making a chair about
to what extent do we do scenario
planning again I think you know this is
something that needs to be understood
well by all councilors and therefore I
think it should be Workshop actually but
I mean if I give just one example
uh I mean we're assuming I'm not
assuming there's some yeah but the
Assumption which is made in here is that
if Ty continues in population will
increase by about five thousand
if Ty goes then population will increase
by four thousand
now all previous workers suggested about
2 300 jobs
overall the community rely on Ty you can
double the population effect because
those individuals have families
so you might say well there is a minus 5
000 potential if Ty closes so how does
it how why do we assume plus four
thousand and that's because throughout
the just transition work has been
assumed that new Industries have come in
to take the place
what if they don't right and we've
already seen you know three significant
hits in just the last couple of months
through oats aquaculture H J Smith
so scenario planning around what if they
don't and what if population declines as
is realistic scenario it is less likely
and therefore it should not be the
central estimate but it's a realistic
scenario and therefore you know the
reason why I think that some of the the
downside risk you know does need to be
be great for upside risk but it's a
downside risk it probably was consensus
you know it does need to be
um you know modeled and again you know
debated you know by Phil cancer rather
than by sort of five years who've turned
up order and risk
I have a feeling like you had your hand
up and I I might have ignored it sorry
that's right did you want to say
something it really goes back and
touches on the lease it really is what
is the process that this committee is
required to go through when it sees this
sort of material and I apologize to a
certain extent I could have assisted in
leading a little bit further through
that and chair you touched on is what is
the impact of the likelihood and the
consequence and I touched on in my
earlier comments
it's where that is outside council's
risk appetite that this committee should
be concerned
um and as we've all discussed you'll
never get these assumptions correct but
what this committee needs to understand
and how much scenario planning it does
is if the impact has Rhiannon touched on
if a significant event occurs are you
satisfied that that Council response in
essence is sufficient to ensure that you
stay as close as you can to within
council's risk appetite but more
importantly council's risk tolerance and
there's a number of risks in here which
when you look at the table that the
chair referred to
Force Council to revisit its long-term
plan now to my mind and and this
committee and Council might form a
different view if you are having to
rework your fundamental document to
adjust for something that occurred then
that occurrence is outside your
tolerance uh and it's a concept we
haven't discussed here but risk appetite
is sort of what I've adopt risk
tolerance once you eat that it's where
it hurts me I mean uh risk tolerance I
have to put my rights up 15 I'm not
going to tolerate that therefore what
mitigations do I have in place what is
council's response to ensure that we
never hit the risk tolerance and that's
the conversation that this committee
really needs to be focused on in terms
of we've got some risks here most of
them won't be able to control we won't
know what inflation will do we'll put
our business estimate in based on all
the information available but we know
we'll get it wrong
what is the consequence of being wrong
on that and a number of things on our
risk not appetite because we've adopted
our appetite when we accept that
when does it start to hurt our tolerance
when would we say we need to put in
place mitigations more mitigations to
ensure that when this risk is eventually
eventuated doesn't hurt us and that's
really the focus around this Committee
in the response so Dewey scenario plan
yes with some of the population growth
where it goes down yes that hurts the
community but to put it bluntly it
doesn't really impact Council that much
population growth is more likely to hurt
us more because we would have to expand
and spend more money to enable that to
occur the population not growing hurts
the ratepayer because the individual
ratepayer might have to pay more but
councils in relatively a neutral
position
sometimes they'll expenditure risk is
worse than our Revenue risk if that
makes sense and it's understanding all
those things and saying okay
looking at that accepting what the risk
is oh and the easy one for me always
comes down to something like if you look
at inflation I mean
it's going to be moderate and modern
which puts it outside our risk appetite
because our Financial Risk is only in
moderate those two things put the the
risk when you combine them at High
okay we can't change that we can't do
anything to reduce that risk lower what
are we going to do to mitigate the
impact when it occurs
and that's where this committee needs to
to my mind needs to be focusing not so
much about the assumptions which is what
everyone said they'll come up to this
committee from somewhere else
but what are we doing about those
assumptions what's what's our response
to where particularly whether outside
our risk appetite
thank you and that's why I asked my
question Andrew I think you already
ended it right and I think you've got
some comments
I was just going to speak to the deputy
mayor's comments about the economic
forecasts
um
so yes that is why it's really important
to think about the extent to which the
assumptions that have been produced by
infometrics that underlie that plan
um are sound and to be aware of where
they have signaled there are some lower
levels of certainty I think they are
fairly certain around the two-y
forecasts obviously that population
numbers they take into account the
broader the whole economic picture so
it's it's it is the whole scenario with
the two-way change layered on top so
that's important to be aware of
um if the agricultural sector does worse
than expected in the model it is
expected to tail off a little bit
and we don't get some of the new
Industries then no doubt we will be in a
different situation than is forecast in
those scenarios and that is a risk that
Council should be aware of
thanks for animal running
um I just want to make a comment about
about how short sometimes our memories
can be and just looking back through
media comments and going back to 1993
and
the comment last one out of invercargill
turn the lights out
was a strong saying the you know the
forecast was was Doom and Gloom the
house prices were prices at all time low
and will I put it down to the tadiri
coming and and providing that that
intensification but so I you know if you
look back in 1993 and what council would
have sat around the table and talked
about everything was out of there
completely out of their influence
and you had
um comments like that and if you look at
where we are now we are analyzing these
risks but they are nowhere in comparison
to making I don't see any statements
from you Rhiannon about switching the
life out except for managing our
emissions counselor
our emissions
now don't get me started on that
yeah yeah yeah yeah but anyway I'm just
saying that we need to you know a little
wee bit of looking back at where where
we have been and where we are
and you can
I think someone mentioned about over
over planning risks that
I mean I'd be War if I was Queenstown
Council I'd be more worried about uh af8
because there's a 75 chance it's going
to go before 2050.
so
um yeah I I this cape is very good
around and and I think it's a there's
people who mentioned it's it's something
for us to talk about yeah
and I think we we um probably
um uh uh uh you know where we are I I
and indeed I think I'm hearing from the
committee obviously in terms of
um
uh there have been a range of
assumptions I think the
comprehensiveness and and the analysis
is is one that is um probably happened
last time but it feels um incredibly
good Rhiannon
I actually want to pick up not the
emission well it could be the emissions
the environmental section
when I look at that
even if I'm thinking short term the
change in weather patterns in flood risk
whether we're thinking long term there
is a sleeper in the middle of us
and I don't know whether I would quite
agree that I'm a bit more negative about
the consequences that we may face
my personal View and and you know I'm
not a weather forecaster
necessarily or anything like that or an
environmentalist in this in the sense of
an expert
and I just wonder
about our assumptions around and comes
back to the scenario modeling
what is the possibility and the downside
so look I I leave that as a as a as a
question because I would like us to to
move on
um Rhiannon and Andrew I think
if there's two things then that we've
discussed one is mine around scenario
and it aligns really with your view how
does what situation could get us to to
an
intolerable position Andrew I think the
the second one is time I take your point
you've made a strong bid that this needs
to be workshopped and I think probably
um the the rich discussion that these
assumptions generate in terms of those
scenarios tend to be the area that you
are starting to go I'm you know starting
to have a reasonable discussion there
isn't one for this committee that's
actually one for you and your planning
committee as to what is most likely and
where you're going to pitch this ltp
along with having some um uh range of
possibilities which will be normal when
you're dealing with these assumptions
okay so I I'm not going to necessarily
put a resolution here that we have a
workshop but I do want Michael team
you've heard a call from the section of
the committee I'd ask that you consider
is the is there something other than
this just being received and then going
up to two other committees adequate from
what you've heard in terms of the
discussion today
so am I a comfortable committee that we
move to the recommendations right thank
you it's more to them we receive we note
the progress for the adoption and you've
got a piece of homework to check out
where our Auditors are with their their
ltp and and we note um and well I thank
you for your feedback we've noted that
um and we can move on I'm going to move
that from the chair that I've seen to
thank you Leslie appreciate that there's
any discussion on the motion
put the motion all those and oh sorry
not just one thing I've been thinking
about uh Grant racing issue there before
um it just seems to me that we
this document drives where we go in our
long-term plan that doesn't give us some
insight into potentials for some issues
we have in the community to be resolved
by way of joint ventures
so I'm going to do a counselor only
meeting shortly to give my colleagues
but another day where I'm at with the
housing issue it's time and leaves here
well aware of
um
but there's huge potential for some of
these issues to be resolved in
partnership with government and
certainly in partnership with local
developers who have a different way of
operating than us just being at the
front and resolving our issues and
understanding aside not sure about what
we can contribute but there's some
potential there I just think that our
long-term plan often just encourages us
on what we can do often in isolation
what we could be doing in Coalition or
partnership with others so I don't know
where you take that issue okay well I
think it's a long-term plan maybe I like
what you're saying um and I think many
councils around the country are thinking
about how do they address
the results of what comes out of this
and it's a bit I mean I wanted I want to
pin what you see back to what Andrew
said and what I've tried to say what
what is the most likely
outcome and what could be the range of
possibilities and and and
um you've expressed that well Tom
because actually we probably will feel
uncomfort at some of those scenarios so
you come back to yourself what can we do
and hence you know some of the questions
you're doing is that sorry some of the
points you're making is is potentially
starting to give some of those
mitigations which makes us more
comfortable as we face what other
consequences or the risks associated
with these assumptions you've got a good
bunch of history in it I just want to
note
um man you might want to think about
whether you're further feedback as we
evolve these but under the housing
assumption
um which is about the housing Supply
rate increasing from 0.5 to 0.7 that is
based on the plans that this council is
intending to do in terms of changing to
the district plan known future
developments and proposed partnership
projects is built into that assumption
so it would if those don't eventuate
then that assumption should be pulled
back so it's just we have factored those
things that you're thinking about
we tend to end up with a long-term plan
which is just what we are going to do
um hear your point I've heard other
councils very much now focused on joint
ventures that realize that there's more
players on the field than us or you've
done it down the road here sure
um for a solution I think of it as I was
running Queen Park this morning okay
um uh we've got a we've we've got three
resolutions as I've said there's a
couple of other themes which I'm asking
particularly you Michael to think
through with Rhiannon about approach
I'll put the motion all those in favor
please say aye those against
carried could I move us to the
resolution to exclude the public I then
intend to take a 10 minute break
here goes the resolution we've got four
matters uh five actually obviously the
minutes health and safety litigation
update
um uh the Financial Risk update which is
really a report back on compliance and
we are going to look at the draft annual
report from uh if we were to flick up a
wee bit lizzle down there are there are
the reasons why that is the case I'm
going to move from the chair that we
move into public excluded or I'm
comfortable for the reasons that have
stated that over significant granted
there's any discussion on the motion
you're being none I'll put it all those
in favor please say aye aye aye Place
against this Carrick Brian thank you can
I suggest we take a break get a cup of
tea